yesterday marked the first full day of
president Trump's impeachment trial the
trial consisted of house impeachment
managers talking and talking and talking
and talking and talking
12 hours upwards of 13 hours of talking
and I was up watching until the very
last minute so that you wouldn't have to
that's my service to the American public
we will examine most important moments
then Hillary throws shade at Bernie
president Trump wrecks the weak elites
at Davos and we announce a fun new
project we actually announced two fun
new projects all that and more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I have not slept in days I've just been
so absolutely riveted by the droning
tedium of Adam Schiff and the House
Democrat impeachment managers you know
within this twelve or thirteen hour
nonsense there actually were a few
really key moments shows you the
radicalism of what's going on right now
in our Congress particularly on the left
the threats that poses to our republic
we'll get to that in a second but first
speaking of threats it's very very
important to protect your identity if
you want a new year's resolution that's
easy to keep there's a very simple one
resolve to help protect your identity in
your personal information with life lock
identity theft protection life lock
gives you everything you need they alert
you to potential threats about your
identity only one in five identity theft
victims are really gonna find out about
it quickly you've got to do it now I
know what you think you think what I
used to think which is that nobody wants
to steal your identity nobody's gonna
get your data it's not a big deal that's
the sort of thing that happens to
somebody else
that is not true it is happening nobody
is totally safe from it everybody's got
your in information out there so make
sure to protect it right now you can get
life lock which is the protection that I
use and I personally rely on you can get
a life lock for up to twenty five
percent off your first year do it right
now I know this is one of those things
that you just are gonna put off into the
future right okay I'll worry about that
tomorrow I'll worry about that the next
day well guess what eventually it's
going to be too late you can you can
take great steps to stop identity theft
but you got to do it now go to LifeLock
comm slash Knowles kayano wles that's
life lock dot-com slash Knowles canna
wles
for up to 25 percent off during this 12
13 hours of absolute nonsense there were
some important moments Adam Schiff is
really the bearer here of the
unconstitutionality he made a lot of
just completely mistaken arguments
yesterday on the Senate floor
he first opens up by a
daling lambasted the Trump Whitehouse
for involving the courts in impeachment
and this is really key it's key to
understanding the the democratic
argument here with impeachment shifts
argument is that the the judiciary the
courts are supposed to have absolutely
nothing to do with impeachment
whatsoever
now they make the further argument that
the house should only be able to peace
after they exhaust all legal remedies as
if the Constitution says the house shall
have the sole power impeachment asterisk
but only after it goes to court in the
district court than the court of appeal
isn't a nun bunk and then the Supreme
Court and it's remanded and they go back
up the chain in six years why didn't the
founders require the exhaustion of legal
remedies because they didn't want to put
the impeachment process in the courts
all right as with most political
speeches there was a little tiny modicum
of truth to what Adam Schiff was saying
but the overall point he's making that
the judiciary is excluded from from
impeachment is just not true how do I
know it's not true because Adam Schiff
was making this argument yesterday in
front of Chief Justice John Roberts who
was presiding over the whole impeachment
trial because that's what the
Constitution demands that he does
obviously there is a role for the
judiciary here what Adam Schiff wants to
pretend is that impeachment is 100%
about the house the House of
Representatives okay well if it's all
about the House of Representatives
how come you Adam Schiff are making this
argument in the impeachment trial in the
Senate obviously it's not only about the
House of Representatives it also
involves the Senate how come you're
making that argument in front of the
Chief Justice who's presiding over the
entire impeachment our founding fathers
gave us a balanced government there are
checks and balances so that not one
Brent one branch of the government does
not get too much power and take over the
other two so you've got the balance here
between the executive and the judiciary
and the legislature and the legislature
is broken up between the House of
Representatives and the Senate Adam
Schiff wants to gloss all over that be
this is a power grab it's a power grab
not just for the House of
Representatives it's a power grab for
the left it's a power grab for Democrats
who never got over the fact that they
lost the 2016 election and so they're
trying to steal the 2016 election again
they were trying to overturn that and in
the process they're trying to steal the
2020 election which was the very
argument that one of president Trump's
lawyers Jay Sekulow made yesterday
president Trump's other lawyer Pat
Cipollone II was having none of Adam
shift's argument so Pat Cipollone is the
White House Counsel he comes out and she
absolutely shoots down shifts dumb
argument they had a court date and they
withdrew the subpoena they evaded a
decision and they're asking you to
become complicit in that evasion of the
courts it's ridiculous and we should
call it out for what it is obstruction
for going to court it's an act of
patriotism to defend the constitutional
rights of the president because if they
can do it to the president they could do
it to any of you and they could do it to
the any American citizen and that's
wrong and Lawrence tribe who's been
advising them I guess he didn't tell you
that in the Clinton impeachment he said
it's dangerous to suggest that invoking
constitutional rights is impeachable
it's dangerous and you know what it is
dangerous mr. Schiff Pat Cipollone II
came right out swinging yesterday I
thought he did an excellent job as
Trump's counsel as his White House
Counsel generally speaking I think the
Republicans did a better job than
Democrats the Democrats made one really
smart move which was at the top of it
Adam Schiff came out and instead of
making arguments about calling witnesses
or about the procedure of how this
impeachment trial is gonna go which was
supposed to be what they were talking
about instead he decided to use the
opportunity to make his opening speech
to the American people after that though
Democrats seemed to lose sight of that
and it just became repetitive it was the
same old thing same old arguments being
made to the Senators whereas
Steam's Apollonian seculow were clearly
making their arguments to the american
people that were making their arguments
to the television cameras and he's
absolutely right you know when you when
you talk about the Justice or the
injustice of this trial what the
Democrats are trying to say is that this
isn't a trial it's a cover-up that's the
new slogan that's the bumper sticker
they're saying this isn't a trial it's a
total miscarriage of justice well what
have we seen so far so far in this
impeachment charade you've got the house
calling witnesses and the house has
tried to get the absolute most damaging
testimony that they could against the
president Trump hasn't been able to call
any witnesses has he Trump hasn't been
able to cross-examine any witnesses has
he Trump hasn't been able to make any of
his case whatsoever it has been
completely one-sided from the House of
Representatives then once the house
exhausted their their witnesses they
called all the people they wanted to
call then they wanted to call some other
people and then they got a little
pushback and then they backed off
because they knew it was going to have
difficult political consequences for
them now they impeach the president it
goes to trial and they're complaining
that they can't get any more witnesses
they had their chance
they have run roughshod over the norms
of this country they've run roughshod
over justice from the very beginning of
this now it's somebody else's turn
that's the argument that Trump's team is
making and it's very good argument the
most sensationalist speech of the day
came of course from the Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer because the most
dangerous place in Washington DC is
between Chuck Schumer and a camera the
man loves the sound of his own voice all
right it's an occupational hazard when
you're in podcasting media politics but
Chuck Schumer really raises it to the
level of a high art form we will get to
Schumer's very very poor argument in a
second and then we will watch president
Trump's lawyer just absolutely smack
that down that we haven't even brought
in the media yet by the way because if
you think the arguments from the
Democrats were bad just wait until you
hear the arguments from the mainstream
media then Hillary Clinton throws some
shade at Bernie which is my favorite
news story of the entire day first we
got to thank our friends over at keeps
if you were watching
that impeachment trial yesterday you'll
notice some of those poor senators they
didn't do what they could to keep their
hair when they were young men and now
they're bald and they don't look so
great I am not exactly an Adonis of a
man okay I am not exactly the most
athletic hulking guy in the world but I
always did pretty good with the ladies
because I had a nice head of hair
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 that's the bad news
the good news with today's advances in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss and it help you keep the hair you
have at half the cost of your local
pharmacy you do not have to go broke to
avoid going bald you don't but you've
got to start now keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there you maybe
you've tried them before I guarantee you
you haven't tried them at this price and
keeps now offers a prescription shampoo
to help keep your scalp healthy to keeps
has just done a tremendous job what can
you do right now
keeps treatments start at just $10 per
month plus for a limited time you can
get your first month for free if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps calm / Knolls KO wles
to receive your first month of treatment
for free come on fellas give yourself an
advantage even if you're not a hulking
Adonis you know take the same strategy I
have keep the hair you got ke EPS calm /
Knowles canter wles so obviously the
most dangerous place not just in
Washington DC but I think in the known
universe is between Chuck Schumer and a
camera and he gave a great performance
yesterday as always his rage was focused
almost entirely on Republicans decision
not to permit new witnesses in this
stage of the tour they already had their
witnesses during the initial impeachment
investigation and they voted on
impeachment so now they're just
adjudicating the evidence now because
they're desperate because they didn't
get him on anything Democratic senators
want to pretend that witnesses
never called in the first place here's
Chuck Schumer the McConnell resolution
will result in a rush trial with little
evidence in the dark of night literally
the dark of night if the president is so
confident in his case if Leader
McConnell is so confident the President
did nothing wrong why don't they want
the case to be presented in broad
daylight on something as important as
impeachment the McConnell resolution is
nothing short of a national disgrace
this will go down this resolution as one
of the darker moments in the Senate
history perhaps one of even the darkest
one of the darkest moments in Senate
history that the Senate is conducting an
impeachment trial in almost exactly the
same way they conducted the impeachment
trial of Bill Clinton 20 years ago one
of the darkest moments in Senate history
other dark moments in Senate history
you've got the caning of Charles Sumner
the senator who was almost killed in a
altercation about the Civil War
you've got Democratic senator Theodore
Bilbo giving one of the longest
filibusters in Senate history to stop
passage of an anti-lynching law that's
pretty dark moment I guess you've got a
number of senators over the years who
were censured and even expelled for
treason for being involved in coup
d'etat against the government those are
doesn't seem like pretty dark moments in
Senate history following the
Constitution and conducting an
impeachment trial doesn't seem like the
darkest moment ever but Senator Schumer
is given to hyperbole
Senator Schumer wants witnesses the
trouble for Senator Schumer this is the
trouble for all these guys who have been
around long time in politics the trouble
here is that Chuck Schumer is on the
record from the Clinton impeachment
which was a little over 20 years ago
explaining why there
is no reason after the house has
investigated and impeached to have any
more testimony from witnesses during the
Senate trial but let me say this idea
that they didn't have to call witnesses
in the house and they should call him in
the Senate doesn't make sense you call
witnesses before a grand jury and you
call witnesses before a trial so there
were some on my side I was not among
them but some on my side who argued
strongly that they ought to call
witnesses and they resisted it every
step of the way there has not been a
good explanation why 60,000 pages of
testimony was good enough for the house
but isn't good enough for the Senate
this is the downside of cameras chuck
schumer chuck schumer's never had a
thought
that he hasn't put on a television
camera and the trouble with that is now
we can look back look there's a lot of
hypocrisy that's going around on this
impeachment questions mostly on the left
but a little bit on the right - a little
bit with Republicans - even with non
partisans or what you might call civil
libertarians like Alan Dershowitz who is
a lifelong Democrat lawyer who happens
to now be on Trump's legal team but only
in a limited way to defend the
Constitution Alan Dershowitz said during
the Clinton impeachment that there was
not a particularly strong legal
requirement for impeachment in other
words you didn't have to commit a narrow
definition of a crime in order to be
impeached he's now changed his mind on
this and he was asked about the
difference of opinion and at least Alan
Dershowitz to his credit came out and
said oh yeah I changed my mind I know
more now than I do then I'm a scholar
I'm a Harvard professor that what we do
is we learn things over time and I was
wrong and I own it at least Alan
Dershowitz is owning it the rest of
these guys don't want to own it chuck
schumer just wants to evade the question
schumer thinks this will go down as one
of the darkest moments in Senate history
it may it really may but not for the
reason Schumer thinks one of the darkest
moments in Senate history came in 1868
and that was when the Senate almost
removed
President Johnson from office because
they didn't like him he had not
committed an impeachable offense they
just didn't
like him and they were about to remove
him from office and then his presidency
was saved and our constitutional order
you might say was saved by the one
senator who decided not to vote to
convict and what this did the reason
that this was so important regardless of
your views about 19th century presidents
is that this maintained the
constitutional principle that the
legislature doesn't just get to remove
presidents that they don't like that the
president does not merely serve at the
pleasure of the legislature that there
actually is a separation of powers here
there is a constitutional order that is
not based merely on political raw
interest but is actually guided by
principle and by the guardrails of our
Constitution president Trump's personal
lawyer took this argument even further
calling House Democrats impeachment
unconstitutional we'll get to that in a
second we'll get to bad tapes from the
media and then we'll get to all the
important political implications because
the left is be clowning itself at the
moment but first I have got to thank our
friends over at route insurance route
insurance these guys are really mixing
up the game they are changing the way
car insurance is done because when you
think about car insurance it's a pretty
old model doesn't make a lot of sense I
myself am a good driver when I'm driving
around I see a lot of bad drivers
sometimes I yell things at those bad
drivers why am i paying higher premiums
because of bad drivers this used to
drive me crazy particularly when I was a
young man you know I was a wee little
lad you know a teenage driver because I
thought I'm actually a safe driver I'm
not doing all these crazy things well
these other teenage male drivers are why
am i paying such a higher rate just
because of I don't know though the
classification that I fall into root is
changing the game the way that root is
doing that is because it's charging you
insurance rates based on how you
actually drive it can save you up to
fifty two percent and you just download
the app you take a little test drive it
will it will measure how you are driving
it will pay attention to how you are
driving you can do it right now give
route a try go
to the App Store and download the route
insurance app sign up in less than a
minute to start your test drive today
that is Roo T again download the route
app today or visit join route dot-com to
learn more see how much you could save
the old insurance model does not make a
whole lot of sense route is changing the
game
they are innovating go check them out
okay now Trump's personal lawyer did not
like the arguments that were being put
forward here especially chuck schumer's
argument so he came out here and he said
you know this whole charade is based on
seriously unconstitutional
anti-constitutional actions by the House
Democrats here is Senator Schumer said
earlier today that the eyes of the
founders are on these proceedings Dean
that's true but is the heart of the
Constitution that governs these
proceedings mister shipp also talked
about a trifecta I'll give you a
trifecta during the proceedings that
took place before the Judiciary
Committee the president was denied the
right to cross-examine witnesses the
president was denied the right to access
evidence and the president was denied
the right to have counsel present at
hearings that's a trifecta a trifecta
that violates the Constitution of the
United States absolutely right and I'm
really glad that the Trump lawyers were
taking this strategy of bringing their
argument to the American people because
I think there's a lot of cynicism in the
Senate right now I don't think that
anyone changed their vote yesterday any
of the actual senators I think this was
a partisan impeachment vote from the
House Democrats and it's being viewed as
it is which is is merely a partisan
political exercise and so the Senate is
not taking these arguments seriously but
the American people the ones who are
listening and maybe you're not listening
to 13 hours of it but but you might be
listening to shows such as mine where
we're breaking down the key moments they
are paying attention and I think it's an
important civics lesson that's coming
out the absolute dumbest take on
impeachment came not from one of the
senators or one of the house and Peecher
and managers it came from philip bump
national correspondent for
Washington Post Philip bump tweeted out
quote imagine a criminal trial in which
half the jury was friends with the
accused the accused could ignore
subpoenas and if evidence emerged after
the indictment it wasn't admissible he's
saying this trial the impeachment trial
is so unfair
because that's not being conducted in
the same way as a criminal trial right
now imagine an olympic trial that didn't
have ski slopes and uniforms imagine
that kind of trial it's almost as if
there are different sorts of trials
there are different try there are sports
trials there are criminal trials there
are impeachment trials of course an
impeachment trial is categorically
different from any other kind of trial
an impeachment trial is inherently
political there is no sort of
impeachment trial in which a large
portion of the jury is not going to be
friends with the accused because the
Senators are the jury we have different
rules for these different kinds of
trials to conflate the two to try to
make it seem like Trump is OJ here or
something that is in a regular old
criminal trial is just either insincere
which is what I suspect it is or
profoundly profoundly ignorant either
way Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness is really living up to its
motto it's actually pushing the motto
straight forward ahead
beyond impeachment obviously we will
we'll keep talking about impeachment a
little bit we could bring you the
updates but I think we've covered most
of the important points right now this
is going to go on and on and on and
actually I've got a new project that
we'll be announcing a little bit later
which will help us examine impeachment
but I want to move to the political side
here for 2020 because impeachment is
harming certain presidential candidates
it's harming Elizabeth Warren who's got
to sit in trial it's harming Bernie
Sanders who's got to sit in the trial
you got to remember we're what 17 days
away now from Iowa this is crucial
campaign time and this impeachment trial
is dragging it out
really hurting their campaigns the big
winner in all of it is Joe Biden because
Joe Biden doesn't have to sit on the
jury anymore because Joe Biden is no
longer in the Senate part of me wonders
if the whole reason they're dragging
this out and the Democrats are so
insistent on having a long impeachment
trial is just because they're desperate
to steal the Democratic nomination from
Bernie Sanders again and it's the whole
Democratic establishment that's trying
to steal it Hillary Clinton now is
throwing a whole lot of shade at Bernie
you would think she would content
herself with stealing the election from
him last time but no she's going further
she's going after him again in a new
documentary Hillary Clinton says that
Bernie got nothing done quote in his
career and that he is a quote career
politician she goes on she was she was
asked if she would endorse Bernie
Sanders if he got the nomination and she
refused to do it she said I'm not going
to go there yet we're still in a very
vigorous primary season I will say
however that it's not only him it's the
culture around him it's his leadership
team it's his prominent supporters it's
his online Bernie Bros and their
relentless attacks on lots of his
competitors particularly the women so
she's saying she might not endorse him
this is almost certainly going to help
Bernie nothing like being attacked by
Hillary Clinton to make your approval
ratings go up Hillary Clinton is the
woman who let Trump win Hillary Clinton
is the woman who failed to stop Donald
Trump
and she's the woman who stole the
nomination from Bernie Sanders in 2016
she's over this will help Bernie this
will help him with the base it'll help
him with his base in particular this is
also going to help Trump because what
this does to have Hillary Clinton come
out and more or less called Bernie
Sanders or at least his supporters
misogynists anti-woman
sexist is to deprive her previous
attacks of Trump on Trump of credibility
it takes away the credibility that she
had when she said Trump and his
supporters are deplorable and
irredeemable remember that in 26
Steen she said these Trump supporters
there are no ordinary conservatives
they're deplorable they're irredeemable
Trump is a racist sexist this is that is
okay you can level that you can throw
that kind of attack at somebody but if
you throw that kind of attack at
everybody then it no longer has any
power if Bernie Sanders is a misogynist
if Bernie Sanders is a deplorable then
nobody is a deplorable then Hillary
Clinton is just a bitter woman he's
willing to absolutely malign and slander
anybody who tries to get in the way of
her ambition it's gonna backfire again
as so many things that Hillary Clinton
does now in Hillary's defense I never
thought I would uh Terr those three
words next to one another in Hillary's
defense Bernie Sanders is a stone-cold
communist okay this guy is a radical he
was around st. Petersburg when he felt
it was time for a change
he was probably personal friends with
Karl Marx Bernie Sanders and his
supporters are pushing into the extremes
of American politics and there is a new
video app from James O'Keefe at Project
Veritas showing a Sanders field
organizer another Sanders field
organizer not the one they they
interviewed last time calling for
violent revolution defending the Soviet
Union defending the gulags I kid you not
some seriously wicked stuff we'll get to
that we'll get to Warren's latest
ridiculous pandering she wants the
cabinet when when Elizabeth Warren is
elected president to be half female
which is really outrageous of her to
assume the gender of her future cabinet
secretaries abscess not woke at all Liz
we will get to more fake feminism from
the left some great stuff from President
Trump at Davos and by the way some new
projects I want to announce we told you
yesterday a little bit I've got this new
project the book club over at Prager you
this is a show once a month it's going
to come out we're gonna examine some of
the greatest books ever written some of
the books that you need to read to
understand our culture I think we have a
little clip of it right now the first
episode is out as of yesterday I
interviewed Dennis Prager the man
himself about
Victor Frankel's incredible wonderful
book man's search for meaning here's a
little clip but I learned from him that
the greatest human need more than sex
so this supplants freud and more than
economics disciplines marx is meaning
you can be poor you can it be sexless
but if you have meaning you can be happy
this is what you could be rich and have
sex no meaning no happy alright I I'm
you know I was a little skeptical of
that lesson when I was in my wayward
youth when I was a young teenage Michael
but it's absolutely correct and there's
so much more to take out of that book so
check that out right now and get it on
YouTube and over Prager you will have
another cool new project that we're
going to announce at the end of the show
today because really I just aspire to be
the the Ryan Seacrest of conservatism I
just want to be working all the time so
we'll announce that other project a
little bit later
before we head over the break I just
want to talk a little bit about the
pro-life cause an issue obviously that
has been at the center of our cultural
battles for a very long time if you are
tuned into the news you're aware just
how obscene the other side has become in
this they now shout their abortions on
TV they call preborn babies parasites
you might remember last year our very
own Ben Shapiro fought back against this
he streamed his show live from the March
for Life in DC which is the biggest
pro-life rally in the country and he
gave a really great speech to the crowds
there for the cause well you might not
know is how much grief this caused all
of us from the pro-abortion movement our
advertisers were targeted by left-wing
fake media watchdogs political
operatives and some of them pulled their
ads from our programs this was not the
first time and very likely won't be the
last time that we were attacked in an
attempt to shut down a pro-life voices
we're not the only targets live action
is one of the the most important voices
in the pro-life movement they do
incredible work in that space raising
awareness and pushing education on the
abortion issue to undercover videos that
expose Planned Parenthood and other
abortion clinics for their horrific
rights abuses they have been banned
live-action from advertising on Twitter
over there calls to defund Planned
Parenthood they've been banned from
Pinterest altogether
for quote spreading medical
misinformation you know that babies are
babies they've also seen their
advertising efforts in their online
distribution restricted depending on the
platform that's why our daily wire.com
members are so important
your membership helps us say no to
advertisers when they cave to left-wing
ideologies you keep our pro-life message
from being canceled and you instead help
it grow louder that is why from now
until January 31st a portion of any
daily wire.com membership will be
donated to live action with the promo
code live action easy enough to remember
to support this important issue so head
on over do that right now
daily wire.com you get the promo code
live action help support life all right
head on over we'll be right back with a
whole lot more
Hilary might be arsenic but Bernie
Sanders is cyanide and she has a point
you know the guy is a real radical and
his ideology is extraordinarily
dangerous new video out from James
O'Keefe undercover shows a Sanders field
organizer calling for violent revolution
and defending the gulags it's a
beautiful thing I don't know that I've
ever heard anyone actually defend the
gulags but now I have from one of Bernie
Sanders's employees candidates
politicians cannot be held responsible
for every kooky thing that every one of
their extremist supporters says one of
their fringe guys however this isn't
just some fringe guy who happens to be
supporting Bernie this is an employee of
the Bernie Sanders campaign this is a
Bernie Sanders field organizer and by
the way I would even give Bernie a
little leeway here too because
campaigns sometimes attract wacky people
but now we're seeing a pattern this is
two field organizers and what two weeks
three weeks who have been caught saying
really extreme radical things and in
this case calling for violent revolution
re-education
gulag is in America that is some
seriously wicked stuff and I suspect the
rot starts at the very top of that
campaign because Bernie Sanders the kind
of goofy old codger that he is might
seem harmless and and even somewhat
endearing he's got that funny voice and
he's got his funny finger that he wags
in the air this is a guy who honeymooned
in the Soviet Union the evil empire a
slave state that enslaved half the world
behind the Iron Curtain and he couldn't
wait to get over there he honeymooned
there he took his shirt off
he swilled vodka and he sang communist
folk songs this is a guy who's defended
the worst regimes on planet Earth of his
entire lifetime this is a guy whose sole
mission in the American government is to
make our governments more closely
resemble these tyrannies like the Soviet
Union and Castro's Cuba and elsewhere
this is a man who explicitly defended
red lines it is wicked wicked wicked
stuff I'm reminded of Pope Leo the 13th
who assailed socialism not because it
was economically inefficient or at least
not merely because it was economically
inefficient but because it was evil he
called it evil he called it a wicked
Confederacy he said it steals the very
gospel itself he said it ought to be it
was a plague it was a pest it has to be
resisted utterly and I think we need to
start speaking of socialism in those
kind of moral terms as well and we we
ought to speak of the people who push
socialism and communism in this case in
those same stark moral terms now only
slightly less radical is Elizabeth
Warren
she's the establishment Arian socialist
she's the one who's you can bring home
to mom Elizabeth Warren's campaign is
flailing all right she had this choice
early on in 2020 which was because she
lies effortlessly she lies out speaks
out of both sides of her mouth she
speaks with forked tongue you might say
she had to decide whether or not she was
gonna go for Joe Biden's supporters or
for Bernie Sanders his supporters is she
gonna be the moderate who's got some
Midwest appeal or is she going to be the
radical socialist Canada and she made
her choice she was going to go for
Bernie's
supporters there's a pretty dumb choice
because Joe Biden doesn't really have a
base of support he doesn't have strong
support Bernie Sanders does he has
fanatical supporters like that wacko
that we just saw on camera so it didn't
work out her campaign which was once
headed to be the nominee I mean she was
she had all the momentum in the race it
has now collapsed and so she's pandering
even more
she's now promising to a point a half
female cabinet if elected here's what
Liz Warren said quote our government
officials can best serve the American
public when they reflect the diversity
of the country itself the federal
government does a dismal job on
diversity and inclusion the share of
Latinas in the federal workforce is
about half that of the entire workforce
so hold on shrunk pause there for a
second that means that Latinas have jobs
in the private sector which pay more and
are way better and more fulfilling and
they're not just all bureaucrats and
somehow in Liz Warren's mind that's a
bad thing anyway moving on she says even
though black women are
disproportionately represented in the
federal workforce they are nearly absent
from its leadership ranks white workers
make up nearly 80 percent of the senior
civil service despite making up only 63
percent of the overall federal workforce
what she says she's gonna do is build a
cabinet and senior leadership team that
reflects the full diversity of America
including at least 50 percent of cabinet
positions filled by women and non-binary
people she caught herself you see that
the headline is it's gonna be half
female but she caught herself because if
the cabinet were half female she would
not be woken up because what about
people who like to pretend that they're
neither male nor female what about
people who think that they're both male
and female or nothing at all or any of
the other 56 imaginary genders so she
says that half of them are gonna be
female or non-binary but if they're half
female or non-binary then they're not
half female it seems like women would
still be slightly underrepresented then
you have all of the other racial and
identity politics statistics I was
waiting for her to tell us the airspeed
velocity of an unladen swallow it's just
random statistics about demographics
being regurgitating what does that have
to do with how America looks
what does that have to do with the real
makeup of America I mean what does it
even mean to have a government that
looks like America Elizabeth Warren and
the left broadly just misunderstands the
point of representative government the
point of representative government is
that we are free to elect our
representatives using our free will and
our faculties of reason if we were gonna
have a president that looks like America
I guess we would never have a black
president again right
black black Americans make up 12% of the
population so if you wanted to have a
president that looked like a America he
could be at most
12% black right so you'd never have a
black board does that mean we can't we
can't elect it was a mistake to elect
Obama well I think it was a mistake to
elect Obama but not because of his race
of course that's not what it means does
it mean the majority of Americans are
women women are most of the population
so does that mean we can never have a
male president again I guess Bernie
Biden Budaj edge they've just all got to
drop out that means we can certainly
never have a gay president homosexuals
make up a small minority of the
population obviously we're never gonna
have a transsexual president we can if
we want a president that simply reflects
what the majority of what Americans look
like in terms of their skin color or
their sexual preferences or their
biological sex
should we just peg representation in
government to racial and sexual
demographics well if we do that we don't
even have to vote do we as we know okay
twelve percent of America's black 51 52
percent are women
three percent are gay what Oh point zero
three percent or transsexual so we're
just gonna those are the those are the
important categories nevermind how we
arrived at which categories to pick or
what about ideological categories are we
going to include people who are
conservative or liberal or socialist
regardless of how you slice it it gets
rid of the entire purpose of
representative government which is our
free will and our faculties of reason to
vote if you just had a government that
looked like America nobody would vote
because you would just pick a few
statistics and put them up there
voting could undermine the demographics
because what if a Hispanic voter votes
for a black candidate well that wouldn't
that would mess up the the demographics
of people who look like America there
those are two different visions the one
vision says we want a representative
government meaning we want people to use
their brains use their free will to pick
the representatives that they want
that's what the Conservatives say what
the left says is your brain doesn't
matter your freewill doesn't matter you
probably shouldn't have freewill anyway
I mean if you ask that Bernie Sanders
field organizer and really the the core
of our identity is in our skin color and
in our genitals
so forget about voting we'll just we'll
just look at the census and pick a
government based on those
characteristics that's an ugly view of
representative government and I think
increasingly it's it's viewed to be
incoherent but the left is always
incoherent on these racial politics and
on sexual politics too I bring up this
example of a tweet about Melania Trump
not simply because there's a photo of
Melania Trump there and she's a very
beautiful and graceful woman and I like
to look at it but because it shows you
the fake feminism of the left Melania
Trump just a few days ago tweeted out
quote it is a great honor to serve the
people of this incredible country
hashtag inauguration day 2017 it was a
picture of Melania at the inauguration
and she looked great and it was a
wonderful day to remember
then some random blue checkmark on
Twitter Jeffrey Gutterman tweeted out
quote to her directly
you are disgusting for marrying a
bastard that was one of the nicer
responses on Twitter qoj eric erickson
is an actor and a blue checkmark tweeted
out do you think it's weird that your
husband wants to have sex with his
daughter
it's disgusting imagine imagine speaking
that way to a woman especially if you're
a man especially a woman you don't know
imagine just walking up to a woman and
saying that to a stranger
how disgusting what a disgusting person
you have to be how ashamed of yourself
you should be for that then there were a
bunch of tweets calling her a hooker
calling her trash calling her all sorts
of horror
things Melania Trump who is a vision not
merely of of physical beauty which she
obviously issues a model but she's got a
lot of grace she's conducted herself as
first lady with a lot of class
she speaks what five languages I mean
she's a role model she is really a
really graceful woman it's not just
Melania who gets that Kellyanne Conway
to has been a target some democratic
execute rational candidate named Pam
Keith decided to just out of the blue
call Kelly and Conway ugly on Twitter
this is someone who was running for
public office in the United States she
said can you believe Kellyanne is 53
today I turned 51 in November and I'm
not even wearing a drop of makeup the
implication being that Kelly and Conway
is just an absolutely hideous and this
this random woman pam keith is is so
physically beautiful which the the
premise of her tweet was not correct
let's leave it at that but even if it
were I mean let's say that this woman
Pam Keith were a supermodel and let's
say the Kelly and Conway really were
unattractive what so who says that to
somebody who would say that to a woman
that's that's building women up right
now the left is so so disingenuous on
women's issues whatever you think of
Donald Trump whatever you think of
conservatives whatever you think of
Republicans Melania Trump and Kellyanne
Conway are two of the most impressive
women in the country Kelly and Conway is
the first woman to ever run a major
Party presidential campaign I think
she's the own the only woman ever to do
that she's certainly the only woman to
ever run a successful presidential
campaign this woman rose up the ranks
she is really good at her job
Melania Trump succeeded as model
she's obviously physically very
beautiful but she's just been diplomatic
in her role she speaks five languages
how many languages do you speak how many
languages does Pam Keith speak she's an
immigrant you know the left is always
talking about how much they love
immigrants but you start with Melania
Trump so disingenuous and it's and you
even see it from so-called male
feminists the creepiest creature on the
planet
it's
so disingenuous and and they're always
prattling on about they're always
talking about it I think they're always
talking about it because they're
projecting so when they say that
conservatives hate women
conservatives are mean to women I I
think they're projecting their own
behaviors and their own their own
inclinations and we should not let them
do it for even two seconds before we go
I got to point out the President Trump
just actually absolutely wrecked the
elites at Davos over the past week you
have the World Economic Forum this is
this gross elitist increasingly
irrelevant forum that goes on brings in
a lot of world leaders though fewer and
fewer show up President Trump gave a
speech there and it was a triumphant
speech it was a victory speech it was a
speech that said hey I showed up here a
few years ago and I told you everything
we were going to do and you all laughed
at me well who's laughing now we've
regained our stride we discovered our
spirit and reawakened the powerful
machinery of American enterprise
America's thriving America's flourishing
and yes America is winning again like
never before just last week alone the
United States concluded two
extraordinary trade deals the agreement
with China and the United States Mexico
Canada agreement the two biggest trade
deals ever made they just happened to
get done in the same week big big win I
mean it reminds me of when Nigel Farage
showed up to the EU after the brexit
vote so this is the British
representative very Pro brexit and he
came there and he said you know I told
you people a little while ago that
pretty soon the United Kingdom would
leave the European Union and you all
laughed at me well who's laughing now
this was president Trump's who's
laughing now moment because so many of
these elites who insists that they know
how to run the world they can run our
lives better than you and I can they
mocked this man mercilessly they said
the sky was gonna fall if he got elected
literally in some cases will get
what President Trump said about the
environment at Davos will try to get to
that tomorrow but they certainly thought
the economy was gonna collapse the
markets are gonna fall we're gonna have
wars were and what happened the opposite
this guy has run the United States and
and therefore run the world in many ways
much better than all of these liberal
elites who's laughing now I think you
and I are that's who is before we go to
I have got to announce a very exciting
new project we've been keeping this a
little bit under wraps you'll notice
that I'm in Washington DC this week in
part that's because I'm excited to go
hang out at the March for Life this
weekend but the reason I came in early
is because we are launching a new
project with senator Ted Cruz that is a
new podcast called verdict with Ted Cruz
I will be co-hosting that project with
the senator we were up until 3:00 or
4:00 in the morning last night because
the impeachment hearings were the
Pietschmann trial was going on and on
and on and at about I don't know 1:30 or
2:00 o'clock finally things wrapped up
over at the Capitol and we got a call
from the senator and he headed straight
from the Capitol straight from the
impeachment trial to our studio we
recorded a 25-minute
episode the first episode of verdict
with Ted Cruz we're gonna be doing that
every single night of the impeachment
trial we're not just gonna be talking
about impeachment though the senator is
going to be breaking down the biggest
issues in in the news in our politics in
our government and nobody is closer to
it obviously then senator Ted Cruz and
he really is one of the most brilliant
political and legal minds in the country
so it's just such a wonderful
opportunity for me to be able to learn
from him and get an insider look at
what's going on in impeachment and in
our government I hope that it's a fun
opportunity for everybody else so make
sure to go listen to that it's on
Spotify and YouTube right now it will be
going up on Apple podcasts momentarily
but head over subscribe right now on
Spotify in YouTube to verdict with Ted
Cruz and we will see you later on and
then after another night of no sleep
we'll be back right here tomorrow I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
you